[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
when we talk about
whatever we want and we got big boy here
big mood big mood big mood he's a big
mood that's right
big mood can we talk sorry are you
offended
i am so sorry oh i like it like like i
said i think i'm gonna change it to bm
maybe bmw i don't know one of the two
yeah oh oh explain what bmw i forgot
already is it big mexican woman
yeah big mexican woman there you go
great job
bmw is big mexican wiener oh i like that
too
oh yeah yeah can we talk about what i
just came out with though real quick
wait did they just grow right now oh
look at this [ __ ] i [ __ ] grew it
right now oh that's tight
huh yeah taking mushrooms yeah it's a
[ __ ] taki
shitake happens we have a shirt that
says that too oh that's cute
this is my new mini mushroom farm
kit you can grow at home baby check this
out it's pretty cool right this took me
about uh
about a week to grow from straight up
how come some parts don't have it
oh it's just the way that it grew i had
to pick some off
it just depends on the roots or whatever
yeah some are little some are big buddy
that's how it goes that's true it's just
like the shower room in jail
[Laughter]
so like when this [ __ ] comes up right
you gotta you gotta pick these guys out
and then all of the
so these guys take up all the food so
you see this one right here this little
nub yeah did you
cut it there or do you no no the base oh
when i when i
puck it you just do that oh he's used to
plucking nubs
little numbers little tiny baby the way
that this works is
actually so imagine the mushrooms are
like your hair so you're just kind of
cutting it the hair
and it keeps growing back it doesn't
grow back on the same spot but it grows
back
other places but the actual mushroom is
in here
cut it do you pluck it not cut it you
pluck it what's inside of that log
this is the mushroom it's actually in
here so the log
is it an actual like wooden log that you
guys put mushroom like
seeds in or whatever or spores yeah
that's what it is oh [ __ ] so the
we grind up a tree yeah and then we
steam it to kill all the bacteria and
[ __ ] yeah and then
it's kind of like particle wood where
you cut when you turn it into a log
shape like this yeah and then you put um
the mushroom babies in here
yeah and then they spread and they
colonize it
and when it's ready it starts growing
mushrooms
what are you gonna say steve nothing i
mean i just imagine you know you're at
home and you got this mushroom thingy
like a chick comes over she's like what
the [ __ ] are you doing
man this will get you so much [ __ ] and
so much dick
do you keep the lid closed or do you
leave it open i leave it open so
son of a [ __ ]
it still survived wow this is like a
cartoon mushroom like this
is so pretty you can cook with these
mushrooms right yeah this is shiitake
mushrooms
you can snort it too it's like me i've
heard that it's japanese jeans but born
in america
oh it smells good too that's it it's
really mushroomy
what do you personally do with it joe i
cook and eat with it so he's going to
eat that i want to see who's going to
eat that mushroom right now
i'll eat it you guys can eat that one
already
you eat it it smells very much for me
after everybody touched it yeah i'll eat
this one over here
i'll eat this one okay let me see you
eat that big one so
i never really ate it raw oh that's huge
but before you guys
it is completely safe to eat i'm just
going to do it like this
that's tight don't you why don't you
stuff the whole thing
you don't have to watch a lot of
mushroom bro come on
don't eat that but no you've ate a
mushroom head before dark man that's
right
that's right there's a lot to true yeah
you don't chew you swallow i thought
no but it's safe to eat well okay
mushrooms you don't want to wash it
oh no you don't want to wash it no oh
because the
liquid gets soaked into it like if you
like a sponge
yeah so brush them off there you go this
guy knows man how about mushrooms you
know about mushroom here
underlining on me underlining yes it's
hella edible you can just eat it freshly
cooked with that chef rush and he made
mushrooms
and he said you don't wash mushrooms you
just wipe them off
wipe a little that's how that's hot like
a dry towel
you get a paper towel you just brush it
and look at it the way that it's grown
is
it there's no dirt you don't need any
dirt it's just water so then you just
brush it off if dust gets on or whatever
it's clean it's cleaner than the ones at
the grocery store because those
kind of get dirty and then fresh
shiitake is a game changer definitely
wash those
it comes with this bottle right here so
you just keep it
so you just keep it humid like this how
how many times did you do that
you spray your mushroom tips all right
yeah
you just do it until the humidity is at
the right
we give you this oh [ __ ] temperature
humidity you see that
you want it around 65 to 70 degrees
it tells you that and it tells you the
humidity right now it says 88
because water got on it it's not really
88
so every kit comes with everything yeah
the mushrooms the
humidity meter thing and it comes with a
brochure but we also have videos too if
you don't want to freaking read
yeah so it has this instructions on how
does the videos you do
no we have our buddy ben doing it he
works at the mushroom farm i wish you
did that
i wish i didn't cause even his
commercial right now i'm laughing
through it
you know it's he's like i'm trying to go
beyond the jk
bottle and he squeezes it twice and
nothing comes out he's like he's like
it's great
the perfect spokesman you could get it
right now for 10 percent off
mk.farm joe all types
so you got your own code get ten percent
off yeah that's dope or is it
martial i don't know i'm gonna leave the
link in the description baby what's from
kingfarm.com though right
yeah but then i'm trying to give them
ten percent off well it's gonna be like
40 bucks
i want them to get a discount if they
get it it's mk.farm
junk and how long does one of these last
if i want to keep my mushrooms coming
it depends on your skills dude so if you
are good
um after this harvest you could get
about three
on average i got up to five and then
that would be like three months
so one log will last you so let's say
you harvest every week
right or like 10 days then it'll last
you like a couple months
cool yeah but we have replacement kits
and all that [ __ ] too
it's really fun let's say you don't take
off any of the mushrooms will it just
keep growing into itself into like a big
bush
yeah what ends up happening well not a
big bush but the mushroom gets big as
[ __ ] and it gets flat
and then um it starts it'll release
pores because it's trying to like
replicate oh because in nature what this
thing does is it'll grow and then
it'll open up yeah and it'll go like
it'll come into the air
it'll like bust [ __ ] nuts and then
shoot
and then that's what i'm saying you need
to do the instructional video why can't
this be
why can't this be a late night as seen
on tv thing where he's like it like
busts a nut in the air and then it's
like
this is for many people they're watching
late at night yeah there you go yeah
well that bus nuts into the log and it
grows more
nah not into the log it'll just go in
and then it just goes into the
atmosphere and hopefully it catches on
to another dead tree
where it will it will colonize that
basically it's like a it's like imagine
if it's elon musk and it's trying to
shoot [ __ ] spaceships
into mars right right and then it's
trying to find mars into the air
and then it it's not all over mars yeah
and it creates
yeah i get it yeah i was trying to do it
cleaner yeah yeah
yeah that makes a lot but that's
basically what it is man this this is
pretty fun
i think um it's you can bust nuts with
the family
it's a great it's a great thing perfect
yep perfect for christmas
perfect for christmas for you to enjoy
with your kids tell them how you can
get your mushrooms to bust nuts into the
sky how did you even get into like the
whole mushroom business
oh man you know i've always wanted a
farm right yeah
so shout outs to the mushroom king josh
he's actually a
fan who built a farm with his dad
in the mushroom business so he this
mushroom is already in whole foods
restaurant depot and all of these
restaurants outside
uh in the in the jersey new york area
his mushrooms are
his mushrooms are in whole foods you can
get it right now um
and then he knows about my farm life and
then he also
is gonna be our junebe matcha franchise
owner in new jersey
and then so when he got into business
with us opening up
uh junebe in the east coast i became
friends with him
and he told me about how he wanted to
get this out to the public
and i was like let's do business and
that's how we got started
nice well it's kind of cool man
i think you guys can get it now for the
holidays
but when you first get it so if i gave
this to my grandmother she's just
opening a log first right
pretty much this is a big piece of [ __ ]
it's like it's like a modern-day chia
pet like you gotta yeah
that you can eat that you could eat yeah
yeah it's a modern-day chia pea you
could eat that's awesome
you eat chia pets yeah they they didn't
market it like that
you eat chia seeds oh yeah that's what
was so boring about chiapas you couldn't
do anything you could actually do
something with this
look at how fat this mushroom is i know
i can't
i don't think i'm gonna get a stomach
egg but we'll see at the end of this
video
you need to come up with your own jingle
sheet she's
talking did you guys ever grow crystals
yeah
yeah the sugar crystal yeah as a kid
that was cool but you couldn't do
anything with it this is where you grow
them well you could eat them yeah you
could eat the sugar crackers i think it
evaporates the water and it turns into
crystals yeah you get these kits how
does it get bigger oh you put like on
this it's like
hanging in water or something or like a
string i forgot yeah take on a string
yeah and then it kind of collects all
the sugar it starts to attract it
yeah so it's like coming into the air so
it's like
grabbing it it's jerking and blowing
nuts yeah yeah or like pooping into the
air
and so if if you're pooping what can you
get what can you do to get your butt
clean
all right because i just did a promo but
i'm gonna do another promo because this
video is brought to you by
hellotushi dudes that promos brought to
you by this promo
i know right they sent me a bidet which
is
a booty cleaner and it is so dang fresh
so dang cool
because i don't have to waste toilet
paper that much
and i can be sure that it feels amazing
i tried it a million times it's like
taking a shower but in between your butt
cheeks yup and we got two of them here
at the office so whenever we get
diarrhea
all of us get in line and then we get
our butt holes clean and it's
one of the safest places to do it so
every hello tushy bidet attachment comes
with a 60 day
risk free happy butt guarantee and a 12
month warranty so you can
have at it you know try to [ __ ] all over
it do whatever you got to do try to
break it if you can
wow but you have 12 months to return it
and that's how awesome they are
stop wiping your butt and start watching
and join the millions of happy hello
tushie customers right now
plus hello tisha is the perfect gift for
the holidays
as they call it holiday yup get 15 off
hello tushy bidets plus free shipping
right now at hellotushi.com
off the record that is hello tushie's
best offer so make sure
your holiday is a little happier and
your brown fried friday is a little
cleaner
by going to hellotushy.com off the
record for 15
off bidets and free shipping thank you
yeah delicious mushrooms i can't wait to
get my kit yep um yours is coming i
can't wait dude it's gonna be a blast
i'm gonna send you
my wife likes uh mushroom pineapple
pizza
and so i'm gonna dice that up put that
on the pizza let me see like instead of
like a hawaiian pizza she replaces a ham
with mushrooms
no ham just pineapple mushrooms yeah are
you a pineapple one pizza kind of guy
yeah i like that pineapple on ham yeah
yeah
more of a pepperoni jalapeno guy on
pizza
oh that sounds like something that's my
[ __ ] that does sound like yeah yeah yeah
like a mom that's bomb right there but i
don't know pineapple on pizza
no pineapples you know what pineapple
still
i'm not a fan of it but like if it's
there i'll put in my mouth oh i won't no
pineapples at all no no i love peppers
oh okay like you know like the
the pineapple turnover thingy whatever
you know how
they make a whole turnover like yeah
never had that like in the 1950s they
made it okay i wasn't born around there
what about what about you know when they
make ham right like for thanksgiving and
they got a pineapple slices on is that
weird to you you know what i just
contradicted myself
because you like pasta no yes el pastor
they have pineapples yeah exactly that's
what made me think of it too and also uh
at the brazilian barbecue place when
they have a grilled one grilled
pineapple cinnamon that's just bumps i
never had that
oh yeah next time you barbecue get
pineapples
yeah yeah i had that i got pineapples oh
really
nah yeah you gotta you gotta grill it
and then you put cinnamon and sugar on
it
do you guys think that hot dogs are
sandwiches
no well this is also part of the grand
the grand debate
are you serious yes that question i
think that the sandwich because the
bread's
long right hell no a hot dog is a hot
dog like a meatball sandwich right
yeah that's the idea i like that
question because it kind of reminds me
of if
wafers are cookies because they're not i
think they are
thank hot dogs or you
or not i think it's a hot dog i think
it's his own category that's a whole
camera yeah yeah
i agree but if i had to i know that's
bart's favorite
uh when they have hot dogs that's his
favorite night of the week
he calls it ladies night now on the pin
they call it ladies night
really yeah it's a sausage and they'll
say it's ladies night
sausage and then do all the all the
inmates get all giggly and blushy about
it
no you just know it's ladies night like
oh it's ladies night and it's a sausage
night what's the best meal you can get
that oh the best yeah if they're like on
sundays or once a month there's like one
good meal
so i would just say breakfast wise
sunday it's called the grand slam but
it's not a gram slam you just get like
some corn flakes you'll get more variety
of like
eggs and maybe some potatoes like real
eggs or like powdered eggs
um they're probably fake eggs i don't
know i never worked in the kitchen
but uh so the best meal is corn flakes
and potatoes and eggs yeah
what a combination yeah uh breakfast
wise i would say like sos
[ __ ] on shingles what the [ __ ] is that
sos
it's like a nasty um ground beef
gravy thing on some potatoes and bread
yeah that sounds good it does sound
bad yeah but when you when you see like
the meat that they use they have like
the veins like you can see the like
tubes
in the meat like the ground even there's
tubes
yeah it's disgusting major arteries but
when you're hungry you're on lockdown
you're gonna eat that
you're on a 2000 calorie diet you know i
would literally die from starvation
you won't have pineapple on pizza
no thanks [ __ ] did you ever were you a
picky eater before in the gym
oh i've always been i mean you wouldn't
think i was that picky but
i'm pretty picky yeah i look like a
picky person
i know are you a picky person now are
you really appreciative of you picky nah
i mean i'm still pretty picky what do
you
hate like what's your name it's like it
repulses you like
ugh i don't really like fish or like
fish because it smells weird
just don't like it i don't know never
really about sushi
nah cause i don't like fish that much
but i like sushi now i like sushi
i mean if you consider a california roll
sushi but no it's not sushi right
fried fish yeah no i don't i don't
really like it but i like shrimp
i was about to say like yeah yeah oh
yeah eat that
shellfish like lobster yeah yeah so
lobsters are right
i just kind of tried crab for the first
time a little bit and
crab i thought was better than lobster i
like crab better
that's my [ __ ] i never knew that in
those legs way better than lobster i
thought
lobster is all the hype right like
lobster is really good
yeah that's true because crevice cheaper
crabs bomb
those keen crabs so sweet crab legs yeah
that [ __ ] is bomb i like onions really
me too i hate onions and everyone judges
me for that what about onions and
cilantro and tacos
i mean no oh eat it but i'd rather have
it
i mean i'll do cilantro but no onions no
onions i
hate i'm not really but it but yeah what
about like
on your in-n-out burger no onions at all
no grilled never ever no sauce for me
either
no sausages no sausage in and out i used
to do that too
it actually tastes fresh
oh really i feel like i order things
just for the sauce
like fries is just a sauce delivery
service
you know like ketchup yeah for any sauce
i love sauces like if i get nuggets
i'll get like five different sauces me
too you're my kind of guy
i love sausage you don't like sauces but
you'll eat [ __ ] on shingles
i was forced no when you're hungry you
just eat it you're very inconsistent my
friend
you you got to eat what you do is right
so if you got this nasty plate of food
you go for
when you're the hungriest you eat the
nastiest first and
uh you know on the best for last because
the nastiest when you're hungry you
don't even care [ __ ] tastes good
eating those mixed vegetables you're
eating them nasty stuff and then
then you eat the better stuff that's the
key what's the first thing you ate
getting out of jail
oh yeah all right oh okay so i had this
whole mindset right when i get out of
jail i'm gonna have
a pizza a burrito um
what else did that uh burger from where
though from where
they didn't matter i just anywhere and i
was like i'm gonna buy his burrito
buy the pizza bite of a burger whatever
i couldn't eat it together huh yeah just
so so
man i was looking forward to that but it
kind of worked against me like you're
just kind of into
institutionalized i could barely eat i
dropped like maybe
um a cool like 20 pounds when i got out
of prison because i couldn't eat
you're just like institutionalized you
don't want to eat you're just tripping
out you know on
being out here like you don't have an
appetite yeah yeah no appetite oh crazy
yeah i just
i just pounded some beers instead what
if you start getting in line with the
metal tray do you get more of appetite
you're out of [ __ ] denny's and [ __ ]
with a metal trick this guy's a dick
this guy's a true dick right here
you know i know i shoulda shoulda get in
the cafeteria you would have felt so at
home getting like indian food in those
big metal trays
oh yeah really i don't know so you
couldn't
get the pizza and the burrito and the i
did but i barely could eat it was this
weird you know
[ __ ] i remember hit the liquor store
trauma dude you were like four years
in trauma like through trauma you're
just seeing you're it's repetitive
everything you eat
like the colors the sounds i mean you
would
every sound and color and food is all
the same you know
it's repetitive so like if you hear
you know someone walking like the ceo
okay it's keys the ceo's walking you
hear scuffling
someone's getting down you hear the
alarm go off okay there's
like you know every sound so like if
we're in this room right and i hear
scuffling
i think damn someone must be getting
down you know like you know
sounds like like no other you don't hear
anything else afterwards yeah this
is you you know everything you know
change the way you sleep and stuff too
oh yeah
um nah i slept pretty good like coming
out even
yeah i mean you just got to figure like
uh well no when i got out
it was like i wanted to experience life
so i was staying up i was
i felt like i had you got to figure
you're doing
every single day the same for all if
if you want your time to go by you know
fast
it's all it's all a program you know if
you're going day by day just
thinking about what you're going to do
every single day your time is going to
go so damn slow
but if you set a program every day right
in the morning i'm gonna bang out these
push-ups i'm gonna go to ciao
i'm gonna come back make whatever make
my bed clean up
i'm gonna hit the yard like you have
your schedule your program every single
day you do that every single day
so you know at noon is this you know
three is this four is this five at this
you know eight o'clock is this i'm gonna
hit the sack every day the same
but that's how you make your day go by
you know when you have your day off or
something like that your day drags out
what am i gonna do today
uh you know but you set that program
your dates fly is your are your days
like that now as a schedule
um i try to be programmed
i try to be but no not really so hard
with like
your own business and making content and
[ __ ] like that and
it's pretty all over the place you kind
of got to adapt but um
i guess i have a program with like just
shooting and then
you know doing business stuff and things
like that but thanks you're in there for
four years you missed like a lot of game
of thrones and stuff huh
i missed a lot of stuff i went out i
went in when it was uh
when it was flip phones and it was like
press one
two two three to get the lettering
people
yeah no one even really texts yeah to
getting out all these
you got these type of phones and
smartphones and
full-on no one calls no more yeah it was
a trip about the
all the phones that people have been
sneaking in their booties they didn't
start changing
yeah you like look at this place
when the apple plus came out these guys
are like [ __ ]
all right i've got ipads how am i gonna
sneak this in there
[Music]
so
you